hey guys Pete here this is a video I've
been wanting to do for a long time in
number of episodes we're getting close
to the end of game thrones and we're
beginning to see what that will look
like today I'm going to talk about the
war for the dawn which is where the game
of Thrones has been headed ever since
the beginning for the first six seasons
we watched different characters and
houses fight for power through the war
of the five kings saw three different
kings and one queen sit on the Iron
Throne and now we have an invading force
coming from marine with the intent to
put the Targaryen mother of dragons on
the throne all the while in the
background we've caught glimpses of the
real threat to Westeros the White
Walkers beyond the wall the war for the
dawn comes from prophecy it's a war that
is said to be a war for life itself the
combatants are supposed to be humanity
against the others or in the TV show
they call them the white walkers it's a
conflict between good and bad light and
dark or however you want to frame it the
important part is that there's an
implication that one side won't survive
it at the end
Melisandre describes the war for the
dawn to Davos like this these little
wars are no more than a scuffle of
children before what is to come the one
whose name may not be spoken is
marshalling his power a power fell in
evil and strong beyond measure soon
comes the cold and the night that never
ends unless true men find the courage to
fight it men whose hearts are fired when
she says the one whose name may not be
spoken she's talking about the great
other in her religion there is the lord
of light who is more or less the good
god and the great other that embodies
everything that's evil Melisandre is a
religious fanatic so it can be hard to
take everything she says at face value
or just say okay that must be true also
she has a history of misinterpreting
things and honestly seems wrong more
often than right I talked about this in
my importance of prophecy video which
I'll put a link to right here so I won't
go into the whole concept but what
Melisandre sees generally tends to
happen it's not that she that what she
sees is false but that it's vague which
means there's a good chance the details
that she fills in won't be exactly right
even if you want to discredit the idea
that real or and the great other exists
it should be obvious by now that the
White Walkers will play in
Orton role in the series conclusion the
first scene we see on the show is also
the first scene where the White Walkers
pop up you don't create a supernatural
race of evil creatures just to have them
hang out beyond the wall and never do
anything with them so they've never
really been in the forefront of things
but they've always been there
gaining strength and getting ready to
come and basically attack men beyond
that we have a pretty rich backstory
that is foundational in the way this
world has been put together the wall is
a big part of Game of Thrones and the
wall was built to keep the White Walkers
out humanity may have lost sight of this
in the thousands of years since the last
confrontation but everyone near the wall
right now knows that things are changing
and that something's going on at this
point in time one of the things that
makes George RR Martin's world-building
so interesting to me is the way he
crafts the history of his world in a
realistic way what I mean about this is
that the history we know isn't
necessarily to be trusted just like
history in our own world it's written by
the victors influenced by politics and
different mythologies interpret events
through different lenses if you take the
world book or the world of Ice and Fire
or something like the princess and the
Queen as examples they're written by
maester I mean not literally since
masters aren't real but from the point
of view of maesters instead of laying
out a true historical record from an
omniscient source we get the distorted
views of people who have human
motivations to tell those stories in a
certain light without going too far into
it think about archmaester Gildan
sources for the princess and the Queen
one was mushroom a dwarf fool that
people thought was a lack wit the fact
that he was a lot lack wit caused Nobles
to speak freely around him which meant
he had access to certain sensitive
information
the other was Septon Eustis who had who
was a more pious source their agendas
when spinning tales are completely
different and we see that the truth
likely lies somewhere in the middle of
what each person says with that out of
the way let's look at what we know about
this battle for the dawn the long night
and the last year the battle for the
dawn is the historical thing that
happened in the past the war for the
dawn is the prophesized battle that's
supposed to be coming so what do we know
about this the short answer is not much
considering the effect it had on the
morale we know it happened during the
Age of Heroes and that it was a
legendary battle against the others or
the White Walkers depending on which you
know you choose to call them it marked
the end of the long night and could
possibly be connected to the legends of
the prince that was promised azor Ahai
and the last hero the long night is how
the Westerosi refer to a period when a
terrible darkness fell across the known
world it happened approximately 8,000
years before Aegon's conquest in the
midst of a great winter that lasted for
generations the long night itself lasted
for a generation and laid waste through
famine and terror this natural event by
itself nearly wiped people out but that
wasn't the only thing that the long
night is remembered for legend says that
in the midst of this darkness an army of
apparent supernatural beings emerged
from the northernmost regions of
Westeros these White Walkers came from
the polar regions of the lands of always
winter they wielded razor thin swords of
ice and raised White's to fight the
living the children of the forest and
their allies the first men fought
valiantly against them but were driven
southwards by their advance the White
Walkers were eventually beat back when
it was discovered that weapons made of
dragonglass could kill them the story
goes that the last hero sought out the
children of the forest who gave him this
information and then the last hero
founded the Nights Watch who were able
to drive the others back in the battle
for the dawn that's pretty much all we
know for sure and it's important to
remember that this is the Westerosi
account of the story which differs from
the legends further ease even though
they're different they basically all
tell the same story if you're a show
only fan you might be thinking well what
the hell didn't the children of the
forest create the White Walkers to which
the answer is yes only that hasn't been
revealed in the books yet so nothing
more is known about it we sort of know
that a guy named bran the Builder who
might or might not have been the last
hero built the wall to stop this sort of
thing from happening in the future
I say sort of no because george RR
martin has made comments to the effect
of we don't really know if bran the
Builder ever lives I went into that in
more detail in my video about the wall
coming down so I'm not going to go over
it again but it all ties back to what I
was talking about just a just a minute
ago what do we really know about why the
White Walkers are returning right now if
anything obviously there are deviations
in how they
are depicted in the show compared to the
source material the way I look at it
major events will be the same but how we
get there will be different so I don't
think Dan and Dave made up the idea that
the children on the forests created
White Walkers as a weapon against men
they just changed the details to
simplify things for instance the
children we see in the show are the same
children who made the first white Walker
the three-eyed Raven isn't Brynden
rivers necessarily instead he's a guy
that's been in the weirwood roots for a
thousand years in the books it's more
likely that you know there's been
several different people who sat where
Brendan River sits now and that there
have been generations of the children
that have existed since the time they
made the first white Walker but if the
children created the White Walkers then
what happened to make them turn against
their creation and help the last hero
and what is it about the world right now
that has made them come south again for
the first time in 8,000 years these are
things that we don't know and in the
show I'm not sure we'll ever find out as
the story of the war for the dawn can be
told without giving us a good reason of
why the White Walkers are coming there
is an accountable amount of theories on
why this is happening and I think the
simplest way to look at it is this magic
in general is on the rise throughout the
known world Dragons have hatched in the
east or enter coming back to Westeros
and the books the glass candles are
burning and so on so you can make a case
that the White Walkers are moving now
because of that or something related to
that the other possibility is that men
have broken some sort of pact that was
made at the end of the battle for the
dawn which held the piece in place if
you're thinking well aren't the White
Walkers just demon creatures how do you
make a pact with that well just think
about Craster and his male offspring
obviously they left him and his wives
alone in exchange for the boys so that
would say it's possible to make deals
with them as for why the children of the
forest turned on their own creation it
seems likely that they lost control of
them and instead of just being a threat
to men they ended up threatening the
children as well there's a lot of cool
speculation about why all that stuff is
happening and I would be glad to make
some different videos if there's
interest in it but for now let's just
focus on what we know is going to happen
there is a war coming that will eclipse
any of the conflicts that exist in the
Seven Kingdoms right now whether you
want to use Melisandre's words or say a
different
way that's definitely what's going to
happen the consensus is that the wall
will no longer be standing at the end of
season seven and that season eight will
consist of all the characters that are
still left alive fighting against the
others the white walkers and their
reanimated army of whites are the ice
and men and their dragons are the fire
it's a little bit oversimplified but
that's basically all we need to know so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments how do you think this is all
going to play out who do you think will
come out on top who will lead the men
against the white walkers well some of
our favorite characters sacrifice their
lives and what will be left of the Seven
Kingdoms when it's all said don't please
like the video if you enjoyed it and
please subscribe to my channel I've been
trying to get to answer all of the all
of your questions in the comments and I
really enjoy hearing all your theories
the giveaway is still going on for
subscribers who leave comments when I
hit 18,000 I will pick one subscriber
with a random comment picker and then
send them a copy of the night of the
Seven Kingdoms by george RR martin
subscribe and comment so that you will
automatically be eligible to win thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon